there is a mutant in Marvel Comics that
nobody remembers and this guy's name is
Forget Me Not So this story opens up
basically at the Gan gray school for
Higher Learning where there is a girl
who is stuck in a sh force field the sh
basically being an alien race right
technology the X-Men use sometimes and
because of the nature of this Shield the
more a person wants to get in and is not
supposed to be there the more the shield
will suck you in and actually digest you
right it'll destroy you and so forget me
not appears out of nowhere just totally
takes this girl by surprise right and
she's like who in the world are you and
he's like uh I'm an X-Men an X-Men
whatever doesn't really matter what you
call it but basically I'm a member of
the X-Men team right and this girl does
not believe this guy at all because she
knows everything there is to know about
the X-Men and there's no record of this
guy having ever existed and that's when
he explains he says I have The Uncanny
mutant power of instantly sliding out of
people's attentions and their memories
whenever they look away and he says as a
matter of fact it takes an in incredible
effort just to get you to notice me
right now which just to say keeping her
attention the entire time and so even
then like when she looks away because
her arm is being dragged in she looks
back and she doesn't know who this guy
is so like immediately you could tell
exactly how his power works now the cool
thing is he kind of offers this
explanation as a sort of distraction
because in order to ensure this girl
survives the goal is to get her mind off
of the idea that she wants to get into
the Xavier I'm sorry the Gan gray School
of Higher Learning and so he starts to
tell her his story basically like how
his powers work the different escapades
and Adventures that he's been on and the
cool thing is it all basically picks up
with the age of X now for those of you
guys who don't know about age of X we
have covered that story it's an amazing
story but in effect Legion had basically
altered reality right the mutant with a
million personalities each one with its
own power these Powers vary in what
they're capable of sometimes it's just
being able to control fire sometimes
it's time Trav travel sometimes it's
just outright reality warping on a
massive scale and that's literally what
happened with age of X it was just this
massive alteration to reality itself
where it was a constant War taking place
between what were basically humans and
mutants and it was never ending and the
way this works out right this is one of
the coolest things about it for forget
me not this guy had always struggled
with his power he says the same power
that makes people forget me messes with
visual perception aim every weap we
Telemetry so literally people fire at
him but they always miss and he says
maybe nobody noticed me but hell you
could see where I'd been and if I fell
in battle she'd be there to catch me
Legacy the living Memorial of all the
mutant Fallen The Vault where all our
memories would be preserved now one of
the things to know is that in age of X
because of the nature of the story and
the nature of reality warping
traditional X-Men roles weren't really
what they'd been so in the case of rogue
for example instead of her just being
like an X-Man that would travel around
and you know Gambit was always chasing
after trying to clap the cheeks then
instead it was one of these things where
whenever an X-Man died she would touch
them and their memory would live on in
her right the issue with Forget Me Not
is that he was always hunting to like
die in battle but people always missed
him so he could just never actually die
he is by all standards of measurement
Immortal if we're being honest aside
from the fact that he could presumably
age not enough is known about him to
know what or not he could but the result
here is that he would never actually
become one with Legacy and in fact there
is a point where he's seemingly injured
or at least that seems to be the case
and basically because nobody's looking
at him they all just pass him by because
they don't know that he's there so he
ends up waking up on this battlefield
with like this guy who's injured and of
course this guy's like freaking out
because he's just kind of like you know
oh my God you're a mutant you're going
to kill me all that kind of stuff here's
where the cool thing comes into play
that what ends up happening is the two
of them have a conversation once Forget
Me Not basically earns this guy's trust
right he injects him with antibiotics
because his injury is basically infected
and so on and so forth and this guy
realizes that he's not really there to
kill him but what this guy does is he
starts to say things like I don't think
I'm going to last until morning right
like will you stay with me and the
response to forget me not is like dude
it's just your leg man like I mean as
long as we have it bandaged up and you
got some antibiotics you're going to
survive you're going to be fine right I
mean sure like you used to be an
adventurer like us but then ultimately
took a bullet to the knee and that's no
longer the case but this guy says no
it's not right it's everything I don't
even remember my own name anymore it's
written on my dog tags but it doesn't
mean anything and the response of like
forgive me I was like well that's just
the fever talking right but this guy's
like Calhoun Daniel Calhoun that's my
name and he says say it back to me and
then like forget me not like I mean I
wasn't really listening right and like
he can't remember it right and like
that's where this guy says like you see
what I'm saying like it's just sounds it
has no meaning whatsoever nobody
understands or really even grasps what
anybody's saying here and so what ends
up happening is that this guy just kind
of Fades away right he disappears then
the sun rises and then literally you
have forget me not walking through the
X-Men Citadel right the tower is really
what it's called he's holding this guy's
dog tags he gets to Magneto and he says
hey man like there's something wrong
with all of this right the people that
we're fighting are not real you have to
investigate right just try to remember
someone should look outside the barrier
and see what's out there it might not be
what you think now of course as soon as
Forget Me Not walks away Magneto forgets
that he's there and then forget me not
basically goes out there into the
battlefield and the day starts all over
again and that was the nature of age of
X it was just a repeating Loop right it
was the same fight happening all the
time sometimes the X-Men would die and
they would stay dead sometimes they
would come back but the soldiers would
always always return it was always the
same forces that they were fighting over
and over and over again it was one of
the coolest stories especially when you
got to the end and realized Legion was
the one that was doing it all well
technically it was Legion but not really
Legion right it was it was a really
really cool twist at the end of the
story but the fact remains here right
like ultimately Forget Me Nots like I'm
going to go out there and I'm going to
see what's there now what it does is it
seems to point to the idea that forgive
me not was the reason why age of X ended
in the first place and I'll talk about
why here in a second because switching
back to his conversation with this girl
right like she's momentarily distracted
but not enough to completely take her
mind off of everything and so again like
as a kind of way to get her mind off of
getting into the you know the Gan gray
Institute that basically she's like tell
me more about your story right tell me
more about what's going on and so what
he does is he says like you'd be amazed
how many EX victories get put down to
dumb luck after the dust settled right
bad guys secret layer pops open at
exactly the right time well it must be a
glitch in the system super Sentinel hits
the deck just when it's winning well it
must have run out of fuel some
unforeseen some undeserved and unfor Dex
Maka rocks up right when the team needs
it well fate was on their side right and
he says I'm the human get out of jail
free card still it was unbearable it was
worth it just for the knowledge I was
part of something in general right like
part of something greater than myself
and that's where he talks about this
idea of like being remembered right
because this girl asked the question she
says even if it was only you you were
the only one who knew about like
anything and this guy's response is well
it wasn't simply just me that in fact
professor Charles Xavier figured it out
and he put a kind of mental alarm clock
right a psychic alarm clock in his own
mind once every hour that would be a
reminder to himself did I exist and he
says once an hour that was more than
enough because what it meant is that he
didn't have to feel alone that even if
it was just Professor Xavier
acknowledging his existence it was cool
right because someone out there
remembered him now this is going to
become even more important here in a
minute when he comes across mimic and
Omega because those guys are dope and in
fact they make an amazing case but then
at that point you transition to
basically the aftermath of Avengers
versus X-men when Cyclops had gained a
portion of the Phoenix force and killed
Professor Xavier and so because
Professor X was gone there was no one
there to remember this guy there was no
one there to remember his existence he
was just a person in the world and even
when he was standing there next to storm
and kitty Pride they just walked away
because they weren't looking at him so
they didn't realize he was there and
like that was it and so what this guy
does is he kind of gets tired of this
existence and so he tracks down mimic
and Omega right he says weapon Omega can
absorb the abilities and energy of any
Mutant out there right not just copy it
but actually take your power away the
risk with this is that as he absorbs
that energy he could absorb too much and
he could actually kill you which in fact
he'd almost done to the Xmen on several
occasions weapon Omega was one of these
ridiculously just underrated mutants in
Marvel Comics for his time and with some
of the stuff that guy did his Comics
were dope and he was more than enough
for most of the X-Men out there but
basically you have Forget Me Not who
just like tracks this dude down now of
course mimic for long-standing members
of the X-Men team you guys are aware
that mimik was literally a mutant with
the ability to copy the powers of other
people he was not that dissimilar to
morph from X-Men the Animated Series
where he could copy people's forms and
to a degree copy their abilities or
their powers their strengths different
things like that in fact you saw him do
that in the the episode where morph came
back as a oneman army and like rescued
the X-Men I think it was like what was
it like season season three or season 4
I think that happened but the fact
remains here right that this guy tracks
them down and they're actually working
is a kind of humanitarian team right
going out there and basically dealing
with different threats and helping to
bring an end to whatever crises that
humans are dealing with in the aftermath
of mutant conflicts it's the best that
they can really do because there's even
a case that's kind of made here where
weapon Omega ass forget me not like you
realize what it is that you're asking me
to do right that it could actually kill
you and his response is yes like I'm
willing to take that risk but what
happens once you absorb my power I mean
I don't want to stick you with the same
Cur that I've had all these years and
where weapon Omega kind of asked the
question is it a curse the response of
mimic it's all in the eye of the
beholder right from where we're standing
not being noticed sounds pretty good and
it's one of these things where it's like
I mean sure it does but you don't
understand everything that comes with it
right like to you it sounds awesome but
imagine if like everyone that you ever
knew just forgot that you existed the
instant they look away from you right
like imagine if like mic forgot that you
existed or if Omega forgot that you
existed right he just turns one nod to
the left and then looks back and has no
idea who you are or how you got there
right and so in the midst of this whole
conversation the X-Men show up right
like literally cyclops's X-Men team this
outfit that he has by the way with like
the Red X on his face and everything yes
it's dope we all know it's dope it was
phenomenal when it happened the post
Avengers versus X-men landscape as short
as it was because within like what is it
like a year two years something like
that you went immediately into Secret
Wars it was pretty awesome cyclops
during that time was pretty amazing
honestly in the time leading up to it
after the uh deadly Genesis story when
Vulcan was introduced he was pretty
hardcore but the fact remains that what
you have is Cyclops who in a lot of ways
has just been trying to Rally the
entirety of the mutant population under
his control more or less because he kind
of became a Magneto type character right
like leading a revolution Against
Humanity and that kind of a thing he
wasn't as Extreme as like Magneto from
like the 70s to the 80s but still right
he was following in that kind of
ideology of course mimic and weapon
Omega don't want to have anything to do
with it and in fact they're just kind of
like we're literally cleaning up the
mess that you guys make more often than
not and so because of this and because
of the sheer frustration mimic copies
the powers of every X-Man here takes to
the sky and then immediately launches an
attack against the team and so at that
point it's kind of like okay either a
massive conflict will ensue which given
the power of mimic and what he's capable
of would probably kill all the X-Men
here or forg me not can do something and
so in that moment forgive me not says
like we need a distraction and so what
ends up happening of course is that a
distraction is created and then weapon
Omega copies the powers of Forget Me Not
For a brief moment and then immediately
the X-Men are just like huh that's weird
okay well let's get back home and like
they just leave because they don't know
they're there right because of the
powers of forget me not and that's when
they make the case to them they're like
look man you literally just staved off a
massive catastrophe that would have led
to even more loss of life than what had
already happened right now right so sure
like your powers in a lot of ways you
perceive them as a curse but the reality
here is if you woke up tomorrow and your
powers were gone you're dealing with the
aftermath of your powers having existed
which means he says you have no special
skills no personal or professional
history no family or friends no ties to
anyone or anything and mimik literally
says and it's like the the best point
that he makes here he says take it from
me if you thought you were alone before
wait until people can notice you and
simply just don't care and so it's just
kind of like think it over man like be
sure this is what you want because if
you lose your abilities you won't be
able to do anything in the world right
you'll be worse off than you are right
now and so ultimately he's like okay
like give me a second let me think about
this the two of them turn to face each
other they forget he's there and and
they leave right now of course the
response to forget me on is like I can
find you guys at any point in time right
it's not a great big huge deal but he
just kind of sits back and says like
okay right like you're right it's better
to do something that matters and not be
noticed than the other way around now
comes the hard part actually doing
something that matters and so what you
do is you transition over to the
conversation that he's having with this
girl that was trying to get into the Gan
gray Institute and what he had done is
he had switched places with her right so
now he's stuck in the force field and
this girl is like able to go right she's
able to leave and it's kind of like him
looking at her and saying hey look like
I will probably get out of here
hopefully fingers crossed he's like the
issue is that they changed the door
codes so I could very well just be stuck
in this force field until I ultimately
die of dehydration and starvation right
or I just shout as somebody walks by and
say hey like can you help me out or
something along those lines he's like
but the fact remains here like I could
perish I may not perish but you will be
alive and you can go forward and you can
live your life because the reality of
this girl story is that she had
basically said no to some guys and then
she was ultimately attacked for it and
disfigured and so she had kind of run
away and shown up to the Xavier
Institute trying to find some kind of
Greater meaning for herself or some way
to come to an understanding of like what
her life was going to look like right
where she believed that she could have
some kind of a normal life right and
literally like forgive me not tells this
girl he says the way the world sees you
isn't nearly as important as the way
that you see it and the things you do
make it better and he says big or small
kid it all adds up a legacy worth more
than the person who leaves it and he
says you're beautiful go do something
incredible and she does right she's like
I'll get help right I'll get help right
she turns to run forgets he's there
right just totally forgets that he's
there and she's like that's weird like I
could have sworn there was something
right and then like her phone's ringing
and it's her Mom calling and she talks
to her mom and she's like literally
apologizes like I'm sorry I just ran off
like that right and she kind of comes to
terms with the fact that she is not the
abuse that she suffered right that she
is her own person she suffered a
horrible thing but it does not define
her right and so she kind of makes peace
with her mom and she continues on and
that's where the story ends so it's one
of the coolest Comics that you're ever
going to see but with that being said
guys what were we talking about I don't
know anyway whatever we were talking
about it was probably cool um I will
catch you all in the next
video peace